ho chiesto di aprire la mia pagina
twitter per farvi capire chi sono cosa
faccio cosa penso sui temi del lavoro
tendenzialmente mi occuperei di leggi di
riforme del lavoro ho lavorato sulla
legge biagi sul pacchetto tra prima però
parlando di giovani e lavoro penso che
il tema delle leggi e delle riforme di
cui boeri ha parlato prima
se un aspetto importante ma secondario
ho voluto invece parlare di tirocini di
apprendistato perché penso sofia in
linea con questa serata tutti gli
interventi di prima le bellissime
esperienze di prima
hanno parlato di determinazione di
passione di voglia di mettersi in gioco
non hanno parlato di stabilità
precarietà di contratti immaginiamoci
tanti creativi che erano qui seduti su
un tavolo di un ufficio con l'orologio
timbrava il cartellino quando entrò
abbiamo visto ragazzi che hanno
inventato guardando la televisione e
girando per strada facendo un giro in
moto no quindi il tema del lavoro è
sicuramente un tema complesso dedicato è
sicuramente importante il ruolo delle
istituzioni
il ruolo delle leggi ma prima delle
leggi e dei contratti vengono i mestieri
e le professioni le competenze questo è
quello che vuole il mercato del lavoro
per quello che credo sia importante
parlare di tirocini e di apprendistato
parlando di tirocini si può di nuovo
evidenziare quello che è stato
l'intervento del nostro legislatore
recentemente legislatore ha evidenziato
una criticità nell'uso e soprattutto
nell'abuso dei tirocini formativi e di
orientamento tirocini che vengono
utilizzati come rapporti di lavoro
mascherati da una vernice di formazione
che non c'è mai però poi quando il
legislatore interviene spesso fa più
danni che risolvere i problemi perché la
risposta è che il legislatore ha voluto
dare è stata quella di una paghetta
dello stagista 300 400 500 euro
abbiamo una legislazione e variopinta
macchia di leopardo ogni regione sia
regolamentata come meglio ha ritenuto e
questo paradossalmente ha incentivato
maggiormente le imprese all'abuso di
tirocini io pago io pago per una
prestazione quindi è giusto che il
tirocinante lavori dimenticandosi quello
che invece l'aspetto più importante che
un tirocinio che sia retribuito o meno
un tirocinio importante segnerà la
nostra vita segna la vita dei nostri
ragazzi dei nostri studenti
se ti lascia qualcosa se ti insegna
qualcosa questo è un aspetto che spesso
dimentichiamo quindi in realtà sarebbe
da responsabilizzare il soggetto
promotore colui che firma il tirocinio
il progetto formativo il piano formativo
e poi si disinteressa di quello che
succede al ragazzo quando entra in
un'azienda se veramente sta realizzando
quel piano formativo che è scritto nero
su bianco nel contratto quindi le leggi
possono tanto ma realtà possono ben poco
specialmente con questo mercato del
lavoro che un mercato del lavoro non
solo difficile un mercato lavoro
attraverso da una profonda crisi ma
anche un mercato del lavoro che è
difficile standardizzare ricondurre a
un'unica regola di riferimento per
quello che io sottolineo l'importanza
anche di un altro strumento che si
chiama apprendistato uno strumento che
non piace molto il mio studente non so
perché preferiscono lo stage
forse perché si usa un'espressione
straniera l'apprendistato invece non
piace ma come professore io ho studiato
io sono laureato un bellissimo punteggio
perché missili propone di fare un
percorso formativo perché mi si propone
di fare il ragazzo di bottega
ora innanzitutto lo stage è un percorso
formativo l'apprendistato è un contratto
di lavoro quindi sicuramente è qualcosa
di più pregiato di qualcosa di più
importante nel nostro mercato del lavoro
chiaramente è un percorso ma le storie
che sentivamo prima parlavano di
percorsi di un inizio incerto
un inizio titubante confuso con tante
responsabilità e poi progressivamente
dei passi bellissima e l'immagine di chi
diceva di sognare di avere sogni di
immaginarsi un futuro ben apprendistato
un percorso
noi oggi probabilmente vogliamo tutto e
subito rispetto mondo che ci da poco che
da poco ai giovani però il recuperare
l'idea di un percorso
di un tragitto e soprattutto quello che
questo tragitto può dare l'apprendistato
uno strumento di placement è uno
strumento che avvicina domanda offerti
lavoro non è una fredda selezione guardo
un curriculum mi piace non mi piace lo
prendo lo scarto l'apprendistato e far
crescere qualcosa che c'è in potenza e
la scommessa che fa un'azienda su un
giovane di potenziale che magari non è
ancora pronto per prendersi in pieno la
responsività del ruolo della mansione
che gli viene data ma che con un po di
accompagnamento con della buona
formazione può invece dare i risultati
sperati che significa per il ragazzo una
buona occupazione emma per l'azienda
cambiar pelle far entrare dentro con le
potenzialità quelle energie con la
visione quella creatività che consente
all'impresa di guardare avanti di
guardare al futuro giusto dire che
spetta alla politica spetta al
legislatore disegnare il futuro
costruire il futuro aspetta anche i
giovani spetta anche alle imprese
l'apprendistato è proprio un patto è un
ponte che unisce domanda e offerta di
lavoro
chiaramente l'apprendistato può essere
visto per quello che noi conosciamo
l'apprendistato come un contratto di
ingresso che piace alle imprese perché
si pagano pochi contributi perché puoi
anche pagarlo di meno ma l'apprendistato
può essere anche molto di più
l'apprendistato può essere scuola può
essere università in germania scuola si
diventa apprendisti a 15 anni l'ottanta
per cento degli apprendisti a meno di 20
anni da noi 80 per cento di apprendisti
e più di 20 25 anni
l'apprendistato può essere scuola può
essere università abbiamo una bellissima
esperienza io in tre tweet
ho provato a disegnare un po quello che
era il mio ragionamento tra l'altro
anche la circostanza che il giornalista
maurizio di lucro a cui presente di un
articolo pubblicato sulla nuvola il
corriere che sa raccontare storie belle
perchè me spesso raccontiamo solo le
storie brutte che racconta di un master
che dà lavoro a tutti un master dove
entrano 59 ragazzi 59 ragazzi hanno il
posto di lavoro perché 3 con massimo
apprendistato perché è una di quelle
poche
presentazioni che nel nostro paese si
fanno di quello che è la regola in altri
paesi in francia in particolare per
quanto riguarda questo aspetto
eppure questa storia bella il terzo
tweet è stata massacrata letteralmente
social media su facebook ma non ci credo
come possibile il master nei tagli oggi
non porta nessuna parte porta solo a
finti tirocini sicuramente avranno preso
i raccomandati sicuramente avranno
potuto fare il master quelli che avevano
disponibilità finanziare non è così
ci sono storie brutte ci sono storie
difficili ci sono storie di abusi di
sfruttamento però ci sono anche storie
molto importanti che noi possiamo
trovare quindi l'abilità la capacità di
saper raccontare queste storie come
questa bellissima storia di questo
master certamente in un percorso molto
appetibile per le imprese
un percorso di ingegneria col
politecnico di torino che fa vedere che
è comunque possibile nel nostro paese
portare avanti dei progetti molto
importanti
prima chi ha parlato anche detto cosa
trovi dietro i libri trovo un uomo pe
nell'apprendistato che non è un libro ma
è un contratto è uno strumento di
incontro tra un'azienda e un giovane
anche qui trovo un uomo trova un ragazzo
quindi un'impresa che trova un giovane
trova passioni quelle energie quelle
potenzialità neanche con le difficoltà
quelle incertezze ma soprattutto non ne
parliamo mai il giovane trova un maestro
l'apprendistato funziona nei paesi in
cui c'è la tradizione dei maestri letame
visti prima
i maestri artigiani e maestri di
mestiere quelli che hanno la passione
che fanno un lavoro per passione che non
fanno un lavoro che sono quello che il
mestiere rappresenta e sanno che quel
mestiere dovrà vivere dovrà continuare
in qualcun altro dovrà continuare chino
in giovane che apprende i segreti di
quel mestiere il suo apprendistato io
vedo questo non è un libro su un
apprendista un allievo è un maestro vedo
un uomo
vedo un uomo di esperienza un uomo che
se inserito nel mercato il lavoro è
giunta una certa età trova il piacere
forza la bellezza non l'egoismo di
trasmettere agli altri quello che hai
imparato io questo vedo certamente vedo
il precariato vedo leggi a cui sono
molto affezionato come la legge biagi e
treu che fanno fatica che sono fonte di
polemiche controverse abbiamo visto gli
ultimi interventi che volevano
stabilizzare i posti lavoro legge
fornero bloccando il lavoro temporaneo e
questo ha creato maggiore difficoltà per
i giovani però accanto queste cose io
vedo l'importanza di tornare a parlare
non di contratti ma di persone non di
contratti ma di mestieri professioni
abilità tradizioni che devono essere
passati di generazione in generazione
questo è il mercato lavoro che io
immagino questo mercato del lavoro che
può esserci anche in italia un mercato
lavoro fatto di persone che sanno
costruire il proprio futuro immaginando
le facendo passo dopo passo il percorso
che serve per arrivare a questo
obiettivo
grazie